okay today I'm going to talk about
Newton's personal so Isaac Newton was a
physicist and in the 1660s he worked out
these laws of motion and today we're
going to learn about Newton's first law
so essentially summed up the first law
states that a resultant force is needed
to make something start moving speed up
slow down stop moving or change
direction so we're going to take these
one at a time and see what they actually
mean so let's start off with start
moving so let's imagine right here I
have got a very badly drawn van so
here's my van like this okay so at the
moment at the moment there is no
resultant force there's no overall force
the weight of the van going that way and
the reaction force of balanced and
there's no forces acting in either
direction here so the moment the object
is stationary so when the driver gets in
the car and they start the engine we are
going to have we are going to have a
resultant force now all the resultant
force means is an overall force so if
these arrows are different sizes then
we're going to have acceleration in a
particular direction or a deceleration
getting slower so if as soon as this
person gets in the car and starts here
puts their foot on the on the
accelerator we're gonna start moving so
there's the first way that that
resultant force can happen so we also
could speed up that's our second
scenario so let's imagine right here
we've got a different van now this van
at the moment when we start looking at
it it's traveling at a constant speed I
can tell that it's traveling at a
constant speed or constant velocity if
you will because these arrows are the
same size so it means the forces are
balanced so this stage when the forces
are balanced it's going to carry on
traveling with the same velocity now if
I want to speed up this person's going
to put their foot in the accelerator and
it would cause the force to become
unbalanced this will create a non zero
resultant force that means a resultant
force which has a value as a result this
car here will speed up so what's
happening if a car is to slow down so
again let's go back to the example of a
van again let's imagine at the beginning
of this situation the van here is
traveling at a constant speed so those
are is the same same size
the moment we did not have a resultant
force because the forces are balanced
now this person might see someone
crossing the road they might need to
slow on their brakes so it's going to
increase the friction between the wheels
in the road therefore we are going to
have an unbalanced force creating a
resultant force that way so as a result
because there's an unbalanced force
we're going to have deceleration or
slowing down so slows down okay so we
just need to kind of carry on that idea
a little bit to think about stop moving
because essentially if if we continue to
apply that that brake to this car we
continue to brake eventually this will
come to a stop so that there is also
stop moving so again because you've got
unbalanced forces we have a nonzero
resultant force that means an overall
force that's acting in that direction so
this moving object will come slower and
slower velocity will get lower and lower
until it's stationary stationary means
not moving now the final one to look at
is change direction so let's imagine now
again this van here is driving along the
road let's say it's traveling at a
constant speed I can tell it's traveling
at constant speed because these arrows
are the same size so the moment there's
no resultant force then all of a sudden
another vehicle comes absolutely
crashing into the side of this van let's
say it's gonna cross a red light this
other vehicle come smash
to the side now because of the force
applied here we're gonna have an overall
force which is a resultant force acting
in that direction because the forces
will be unbalanced so we've actually
allowed this vehicle to change direction
so that is the final way that a
resultant force can affect motion so
just to summarize the resultant force is
an overall force when the forces are
unbalanced and there are five different
ways that the moving objects can be
affected and all of the diagrams are
there thank you